[Music]
will I be brave like you one day
remember when I told you to shoot the
deer you said
[Music]
you said no how's it coming along we
finished by the time she's 16.
[Music]
Mr Logan the situation with your son is
dire
but he appears before this court again
he'll be taken from your care
ful how'd you know where I lived right
under some violence
I need your help son
whatever it is just offer me you've
forgotten about Tony McManus no I did
that
question my brother
are you going hunting
sounds cool
Ned we're good it's not yet
[Music]
your soldier
you did what you had to do
what
I'm just wondering
if you know anyone else out there in the
game
got the same skill set as you
you wish she was still here and not me
you want to know I run away come on
because you don't want me Dad
[Music]
we're all just met
we're not Invincible just trying to walk
a line between coverage and fear
don't test me it stops now